the coronavirus pandemic has
challenged humanity like no other crisis
for decades
with millions at risk of dying and many
millions more losing their jobs
it can make climate change seem a second
order problem
tonight's we ask how can we make sure
the recovery from the pandemic is green
how should we confront the challenge of
the climate after
covert
[Music]
a very good evening well today we
learned that the uk's climate assembly
wants the
recovery from coronavirus to be green
polluting new cars it thinks should be
banned in as little as 10 years time
and people should be encouraged to eat
much less dairy
and meat the question is though whether
we're ready
to make those sacrifices well tonight on
climate after covert a green
recovery they're going to be exploring
the climate choices
facing us and the potential solutions
which deliver
green growth with me to do that is our
very special panel they're
assembled from right across the world
we'll meet them in a moment or two
and also with us a virtual international
audience truly international
who'll be questioning them and letting
us know
their views oh yes they will uh hello
and good evening to you all give us a
wave
well uh lots of work for them tonight
but uh first let's get a stock take on
the current state
of climate change from a country where
it's pretty much impossible
to ignore its very clear effects we're
talking about iceland it lies close to
the arctic circle
and about 11 percent of the country is
covered by glaciers
well those glaciers are predicted to
lose up to 35
of their present volume within half a
century or so
now if melted they alone would raise
global sea levels
by one centimeter well that's the future
challenge
but in the present one the country's
health has been
relatively unaffected by coronavirus
with only about one percent of the
population infected
so far but the impact on iceland's
economy
has been very different with visitor
numbers down 80
this year skies adam parsons reports
from one of the country's
most endangered locations
welcome to vatna yokel ice cap it is a
hard place to reach but when you get
here
it is captivating on this island of ice
and fire the ice here is discolored by
volcanic ash sprinkled over it by an
eruption a decade ago
the glacier can survive that but what
might kill it
is us as the world has warmed so the ice
in vatnayoko has melted faster and
faster
over the past 90 years this whole
glacier
has receded by five miles it's never
goodmanson has been studying it for
decades
it's uh devastating actually it's uh
surprising to see how fast this happens
around him this glacier is eroding
before our eyes
a very obvious victim of climate change
water is
gushing into this huge lagoon it was
only formed
86 years ago but from here you can see
how the glacier
is falling icebergs that have broken
away
and this
an ice cave collapsing as we watched
[Music]
as long as the world is getting warmer
the glaciers will retreat in a century
or two
iceland could have very little ice
this new giant lake the ice the cliffs
where the glacier once sawed they're all
a warning about the fragility of our
ecosystem
the question is whether the world is
paying attention
[Music]
well clearly a stunning place and adam
parsons is live on that glacier in
iceland right now and joins me now so as
i say there adam a stunning place but
a stunning rate of loss of ice as well
yeah that is right the sun is about to
set uh here over that new york
it is an extraordinary otherworldly
uh scene i have to say this area
has that sense of brutality of nature
but also of fragility because
this glacier is melting at a pretty
extraordinary rate look at those cliffs
up there they're about 300 meters
tall that's the same height as london's
tallest building the shard
a century ago the ice went right up to
the top of them and if you look into the
distance
you can see what five miles away six
miles away
the glacier used to extend all that way
and yet it has
melted over those hundred years why well
because the world has got hotter and
when
ice heats up then it melts in just the
time i've been talking to you less than
a minute
it's estimated that about seven million
litres of ice have melted from this
glacier alone and that feels to me like
a pretty stark warning to the world
astonishing what a sight thank you adam
well from the freezer
to the fire quite literally our chief
correspondent stuart ramses tonight in
para
in brazil where they're fighting fires
in the amazon rainforest once again
stewart yet more evidence of
of the human effects on climate change
seem to be suggested by the heat that's
here uh dermot that's the rainforest
behind me i'm just going to step out of
the way
it's on fire it's as simple as that
there's no other way of putting it
um we're surrounded by fires we're just
going to keep focusing on these
occasionally the trees will just
uh go alight we've been in here this
region
and inside the forest today and the like
yesterday as well
with the fire brigade who are trying to
control the fires uh here
there are just five of them dermot and
they are they've got
literally hundreds of thousands of
hectares to look after
what they're in doing at the moment
they're still in there is uh trying to
build a fire
uh wall to stop the spread of the flames
into the trees but uh it's it's it's a
difficult battle this fire has been
going on
uh for a week or so have we come down
from this uh
you'll see one of the reasons why these
fires start everything you see in front
of me
is is cattle land it's massive blaze
that was here
that's all burnt as you can see unless
we've seen
many times over the years but very bad
last year and they
think this year could be even worse it
spreads
into the forest the farmer who's been
here with his father for over 20 years
says that
it's simply the climate it is hot hot
hot
it doesn't rain it's been at least three
months and basically
climate change he says it's a reason for
all of this
stu thank you very much indeed stuart
ramsey there in the rainforest in brazil
well as we've just seen two examples of
there
the impact of climate change is being
felt in so
many countries right across the planet
and our audience tonight is also
international we've got people from
india russia iceland zambia nigeria
ghana and the united states as well as
the united kingdom
and ireland so audience i want to get
you working i've got a
first question for you and it's this one
about priorities
which issue do you think should take
precedence
right now coronavirus or the climate now
hands up let's choose one of them hands
up if you believe one hand please
if you believe that coronavirus is the
pressing priority
um quarter mid 25 maybe
maybe 30 percent something like that
think
it's coronavirus so we can assume given
you've all
you all want to take part here that uh
the rest of you think it should be
climate change well it's not just
a virtual audience that we've been
questioning about this the sky news poll
carried out by hugo for us ask people to
tell us
what they think the government's
priorities
should be well uh these are some of the
results and it's almost
a mirror image a flip of what our
virtual audience have said 67 percent
said the coronavirus pandemic and just
15 said climate change the rest said
neither or that they
weren't entirely sure now those findings
are going to be of course of much
interest to our panel let me
introduce them formally then they are
claire o'neill
minister for energy and clean growth
until last year when
she was asked to run the next big global
meeting
to address climate change cop26 a
nomination that was later
withdrawn we've got sally mulhock is one
of the world's
most prominent climate scientists and
director of the international center
for climate change and developments
joined by audrey gallagher
served on the advisory board to the
climate assembly
and his deputy chief executive of energy
uk our quartet is completed with bjorn
longborg
the author of the skeptical
environmentalist uh he doesn't argue
that climate change isn't happening but
says it isn't
an apocalyptic threat well let's hear
from you all uh
first off then indep claire o'neill this
this issue of
priorities the difference between our
audience and and the polling
but um on the polling uh two-thirds of
people think we really should be dealing
with
coronavirus as a priority
well you know honestly i'm not that
surprised by that derma because you know
we have had
nightly hourly news for the last six
months of the coronavirus threat
you know it has been you've been
reporting it constantly
we it's something that everyone has been
talking about we've had the whole
economy shut down
and we haven't had anything like the
same coverage of the climate crisis and
the fact that we currently have
you know the highest level of state uh
fires burning in california we have
cities around the developing world
running out of water and we have
record temperatures now right across the
globe and and i also think there is a
bit of a problem with this that you know
climate change
can feel a bit separated from us in
terms of space and time it's that
classic kind of tragedy of the commons
but you know the climate layer
is 60 miles thick that's it and we've
been conducting an
uncontrolled chemical experiment with
that layer collectively
for the last hundred years that isn't
going to end very well unless we start
to do something about it so
i'm not surprised by that polling i
think we need to all work and i really
commend you actually for doing this
program
to make people realize that this this
this change is happening
but that it isn't apocalyptic you know
this is the world's potentially the
world's biggest economic opportunity
climate recovery uh is both something
that's absolutely necessary and
something will completely transform the
way that we live and do business
and we need to get on with it we're
going to be hearing a lot from you all
during the course of this program sally
milhock bender
your thoughts on those findings on on
the public's view
well i think it's natural that people
are concerned about the public health
crisis
that is actually affecting them their
families and people are
in fact dying immediately on the other
hand climate change is a longer term
problem but it is a big big big problem
and speaking from dhaka in bangladesh i
can tell you
right now part of the country is flooded
it's one of the biggest floods we've had
in
decades and just a couple of months ago
we had a super cyclone
that attacked our coast in the middle of
a pandemic so
the crisis aren't an either or there are
multiple crises that all have to be
dealt with at the same time your
longboard what are your thoughts
i mean do you think perhaps maybe you do
that the public are right in
that ordering of priorities
well i i would be more likely to agree
with saleem
sorry uh salimu so fundamentally
we don't prioritize problems we
prioritize solutions
and we need to realize they're great
covet solutions
where we can spend little money and do
an amazing amount of saving people's
lives
we should definitely do those they're
pretty poor covet solutions where we
spend lots of resources and save almost
no one
we should definitely not beating those
and it's the same with climate there's
some great climate solutions and we
should be doing those there are some
really bad
ineffective climate solutions we
shouldn't be doing those so it's not
about prioritizing
climate versus covet it's about making
sure we do the
smart covet solutions and the smart
climate solutions
and don't do all the dumb ones okay
we're going to be discussing a lot about
those possible solutions during the
course
of the hour and more but let me ask you
then
audrey gallagher it's about the
government's attention i suppose in
terms of priorities
what are your thoughts so i think
obviously the government's going to have
to deal with
the immediate effects of the pandemic
and you know we've got
a public health crisis on our hands and
they really need to get that under
control
um but after that the recovery from
covered it doesn't
we're not talking about a binary choice
here we can do both and in fact you
mentioned the climate
assembly they have said quite clearly
that the recovery of
uh and coming out of we've got to ensure
that we
at what we do is going to contribute
towards meeting the next zero targets
and we're already here in the government
talking about building back better
um you know we're gonna have a clean
green recovery and i really want to see
that happen i think it's possible
um and that's what we should be aiming
for but of course you know
we we need to deal with this public
health crisis first okay your opening
thoughts thank you very much indeed for
them let's get the opening question then
uh from our audience it comes from
dominic pinaya from
london uh very good evening to you
dominic identify yourself
there you are please ask your question
put your question to the panel
um given that governments across the
world have proved how quickly they can
deal with a global emergency
with no expense spared will they now do
the same for the so-called climate
emergency
very good under interesting question uh
sullivan sami
salimo you you come in first on this
this is about i suppose
will and application if the climate
crisis is is real why aren't governments
acting
with such speed and the amount of money
that they are over covered
thank you very much dermott please call
me saleem it's easier to pronounce
um yes thank you i think even even
though the corona virus is not related
to climate change there is a very very
i think message important message
that is a very common message that we
are seeing
play out in dealing with the coronavirus
situation
which is leaders who listened to their
scientists and their epidemiologists
and took action at the right time ended
up
saving lives and the leaders and we
don't need to name them we know who they
are
who did not do that who refused to
listen to the science
have ended up being responsible for
deaths
by the thousands indeed hundreds of
thousands
of their own citizens and that is a
lesson that we need to apply to the
climate change crisis as much as well
because the scientists are telling us
what to do leaders
some are taking the actions required and
i'll mention the prime minister of new
zealand as a good example
and some and mr trump of the united
states
is an example aren't and that is going
to play out to
everybody's detriment going forward so
listen to the scientists
do actions as quickly as possible and i
agree with bjorn
if they are cost effective do them
quickly that that's really what we
need to be doing thank you well okay
well let's bring in bjorn then
and your thoughts are on that question
address it directly if you will from
dominic pania there and he's saying well
look look at the amount of money
governments all around the world are
spending on coronavirus they've
correctly identified it as a crisis and
the fact with
climate change they've been calling it a
crisis for years but
not acting in uh
at the same speed not spending the same
amount of money
yeah so dominic you're absolutely right
we're spending an enormous amount of
money remember
it's mostly money we don't have and we
probably actually can't afford
uh so i i think we should be very wary
of whether we're actually going to spend
them
well just for corona but the real issue
of course is
how do we then get governments to spend
money smartly
for climate and that has to be about
making sure
that we don't just spend lots and lots
of resources and stuff that
looks good that makes everyone feel like
oh we're doing something
one great example of how we're wasting
resources
is when we subsidize for instance
electric cars
that is an incredibly ineffective way to
mostly pay rich people
to drive around these virtuous cars but
cut very very little co2
on the other hand if we could get a lot
of countries to switch at least first
from coal to gas we could dramatically
drive down
carbon emissions at very low cost so
it's about making sure that we spend
resources in places where we can cut
lots of co2 at low cost rather than
doing the opposite
okay what the question is directly
asking though claire o'neil
is i suppose our government's really
just
paying lip service to climate change
because we've seen how
fast and how effectively they can act
when they see
people dying well the short answer to
dominic's great question is no they will
not
turn the taps on and spend the money and
they'll they won't do that for three
reasons one is
uh you know as being said that money is
very short and the politics are that if
you see an nhs in the uk
overwhelmed with patients that's
incredibly bad for your electoral
prospects
if you don't stop uh climate emissions
going up
people don't really notice and so the
you know the short-termism of the
government cycle the average prime
minister globally is in place for about
four years
means that this just simply is not a
priority uh and i spent you know several
years as a minister i bought in the uk's
net zero legislation
um we had wonderful support actually
particularly from prime minister theresa
may
but you know we we we were in a place
for many years where it was not taken
particularly seriously by governments
and i'll just point out that you
mentioned germa that i was the president
designate of the cop
process uh this is the act this is the
annual climate gathering the thing that
led to the paris agreement
uh that's been running was set up in
1992
in rio and since those uh enormously
expensive
huge conferences of happening emissions
have gone up
by about 40 percent so there's an awful
lot of intergovernmental talking
and there's not a lot of action is it
all gloom and doom there will know
because
the question assumes that it's only
governments that tackle
stuff like this and i've got a logo up
behind me i don't if you can see it i've
taken on a new job
at the world business council for
sustainable development because while
governments
are doing some amazing things and
setting out net zero targets
the world's biggest corporations who
understand that if they don't start
investing and don't start taking this
seriously
there will be a huge problem are
starting to move
and uh that kind of expertise is why
you're with us it's why you're all with
us sir
audrey on this issue of government's
will and action is it the fact that
coronavirus just hit us with such
speed and that's in a way climate change
is creeping up on us
so clearly we've seen that there had to
be a response to that i think though as
we we mentioned before it does represent
a good opportunity to know and
try and take some action ensure that we
can address climate change
the government's going to have to go out
and borrow lots and lots of money for
the recovery from covert
let's make sure that any fiscal stimulus
packages that are going in places
bjorn said we're doing it in a
sustainable way we're investing in
um technology and sectors where there's
a real future and we can
we can tackle climate change this is
offered as an opportunity
i think people have also seen that they
can live differently
um because the whole thing about about
climate change
yeah we are tackling climate change of
course we need government intervention
we need
plans from them um we need a clear
policy framework in order to bring
forward investment
but there's also going to have to be a
significant change to people's behavior
and i think that's something that we we
just haven't really started the
conversation with people around that
people don't really understand what this
might mean for them
and and i think we have to do that as
well as just relying on government this
is not something that governments can
deliver
claire mentioned bringing in businesses
but we need to take the public with us
as well
everybody's going to have to change
significantly to get this done
okay well let's get on thank you all for
for that but let's
get on to this this climate assembly
because it's so one thing to accept that
climate change
is still despite coronavirus the most
pressing issue facing the world
it's quite another perhaps to agree on
what to do about it well as we've heard
the uk climate assembly which
reported today wants some significant
changes let's take you through just some
of its suggestions nearly
four in five of the climate assembly
members 79
nearly 80 agreed that the recovery from
covert should
be green and these are some of the
actions to get there 80 percent of them
recommended that taxes for flying should
increase as people fly more often
or further frequent flyers should be
penalized they also say
people voluntarily should reduce their
meat and
dairy consumption buy up to 40 so
are people prepared to make those kind
of sacrifices and many others our sky
news poll for this program suggests
well it depends the most popular policy
to aid a green recovery
was continued encouragement for people
to work
from home with 64 nearly two-thirds in
favor versus just
20 percent opposed now that idea
of encouraging people to eat less dairy
and meat
was the least popular that we tested
with just 33 percent a third
in favor 53 were opposed to that
suggestion and there was little
confidence
in uk political leaders over climate
change
when we asked who people thought cared
the most
out of boris johnson kia starman nicola
sturgeon and the leader of the lib dems
ed davey 35
said none of the above well let's bring
in
uh audience right here and i want to ask
you what do you
make of that poll uh let's get your
hands up again would you like to see
action
for example to encourage people to eat
less meat
and dairy produce would you like to see
that actively discouraged by
governments and uh nearly all of you
just stay with us and let me ask you a
slightly uh different version of that
are you making efforts yourselves right
now
to to do that to change your diets
okay so more than half but a few you
then want what a bit of encouragement
from your governments and on the subject
of encouraging better behavior versus
enforcing it
is our next question this comes from
danny hurley
in clitherow hello there danny please
put your point to our panel
hi everyone uh given the government's
draconian approach to tackling the
pandemic
would a more authoritarian solution to
reducing greenhouse gas emissions
be more effective than a liberal one
well well danny very good question let's
see what our panelists make of this
bjorn lomborg well we've seen we've
heard just in the last few days in
in the uk about covid marshall's laws to
stop
people uh gathering in groups above six
it's the law people will be penalized
people will be fined who knows
people may go to jail what about when it
comes to the climate then we've got
coveted marshals couldn't we have
climate change marshals telling people
to recycle and turn their engines off
well i mean i think first of all there's
actually been quite a number of people
suggesting this
uh but ethically i can't imagine that
anyone would really support this
you can't say that you want to have a
democracy but then for some things you
actually want to be authoritarian
i think we need to recognize that this
is something where we have to convince
people to do this on the merits of the
proposals which of course again goes
back to saying
look you really only need an
authoritarian government if you're going
to
carry through policies that people
wouldn't otherwise
support that's why we need to find
solutions that people will actually
support
rather than going in the other direction
and say we should go authoritarian i
think that's a terrible argument
what do you think audrey gallagher yeah
i think it would be an absolute disaster
if
if we try to impose this on people
because you're talking about you know up
until now we've we've we've done a big
job of decarbonizing the power supply in
the country
but you don't notice when you switch the
light on that you're using beginner
electricity
the changes that are going to be
required are going to be quite
significant about you
as you've outlined how you how much you
travel
what you're allowing what you eat that
can't be imposed on people
and i think what the climate assembly
has shown is that if you educate people
if you give them the information then
they can start making some of the
trade-offs and make some of the choices
and that's going to be really really
important but i think probably the most
important thing about
all of this um is fairness so
you know there is an issue about it's
going to be difficult to reach net zero
but how we do it not if we do it is
going to be just as important
because you know this is coming at a
significant a significant impact on
people's lives
potentially at significant costs and we
need to make sure that that's born
properly
and we need to take people with us in
order to do that because it is a huge
undertaking
i know you know what i'm going to go
back to to danny and say you asked the
question
and what by asking it was it's the fact
that you actually would like to see
governments legislate perhaps put into
law criminalize
a behavior that affects the climate
no i understand that authoritarian's a
very strong word
and i agree with what the panelists have
said but if i was to define the liberal
approach to being
the paris agreements um i think it was
emily o'neil who said that
since the parish agreement was
introduced that emissions have increased
40
so the reason why that's failed in my
opinion is because the paris agreement
is
uh it relies on naturally determined
contributions so in effect
countries can choose their own targets
they can set their own targets
so that to me proves that targets can be
missed they
are being missed so banning certain uses
of fossil fuels would surely
be the most effective way to do it and
to do it by deadline would
allow a smoother economic transition as
well well great question thank you very
much indeed for that danny
and a great answer which you know what
uh has got all
our panelists i don't know if you can
all see each other but all nodding
in agreement uh that perhaps it's got to
be carrot
and not stick thank you very much indeed
for that contribution
uh danny from clitherow now we want to
discuss
now another and it flows directly from
the issue of coronavirus and the
the steps that are being taken to try to
deal with it we've got uh miranda
collette who lives in jersey who
wants to ask um a very specific question
don't you miranda put it to us please
okay i'm concerned about the plastic
waste that's accumulating through ppe
and disposable masks and gloves um the
pandemic seems to have set the
anti-plastic movement back a few years
is there anyone dealing with this and
how are ppe
items recycled yeah and just while i'm
with you miranda i mean you're on jersey
as i say you must see the effects of
plastic waste on the shores every day we
certainly do
yeah um luckily some of us regularly
pick up all the plastic around our
beaches
good for you okay well let me put that
point to to claire o'neil and i mean
there is a huge amount we're talking
about
billions of individual items single-use
items of ppe
being discarded on a daily basis around
the world and we're here
today in the united kingdom and ambition
for instance to carry out something like
10 million coronavirus tests per day
they presumably will be disposable
that's an awful lot more plastic what
are your thoughts clara neil
well i think it's a great question a
couple of years ago we when we had
actually i think skye
did a lot of coverage on this when we
had the great blue blue uh blue ocean
series
we got really concerned about the
long-term impact of plastic waste and we
made huge progress actually both in the
uk and elsewhere
you know and i've been very struck by
the fact that uh you see a lot of
discarded masks
you can no longer use reusable coffee
cups uh you know we all carry those
around
to try and do our bit and i think this
is a fabulous question because it shows
the kind of unintended consequences of
some of these decisions
the good news is a lot of this stuff is
incinerated i mean i know there are
questions about air quality but when
it's used in hospital settings it tends
to be incinerated
and i think we have to encourage people
to actually start you start again as
citizens using their own reusable
uh things and can i can you bear with it
if i just go back i wanted to go back to
danny's question just for 10 seconds
having brought in a number of laws in
the climate space
um you can't be authoritarian as a
government but you can
lead and things like the banning of
fossil fuel vehicles on our roads which
uh
audrey's climate assembly thought was a
really good thing that was actually the
most controversial thing that we did in
the last few years and so i think
governments have a massive role to play
in leading on this and it's been rather
depressing that
none of the government leaders or none
of my old mates
around the cabinet table i think have
met have ever mentioned publicly
the issue of plastic waste having made
such a focus of it so i do think we need
governments to recognize this problem
and come up with some solutions this is
a simple solution just want a quick
thought from salim i mean again you must
see
in in bangladesh the the effects of
plastic pollution in the oceans
on a daily basis and this coronavirus
pandemic is only making it worse but is
it a necessary evil
well definitely we see this and but
interestingly you know bangladesh was
one of the first countries to bla
ban plastic bags used in in dhaka city
we don't
use plastic bags here anymore because
it's been banned and everybody's now
gone to using other kinds of bags
instead so
it is possible to get people to change
and and change behavior
but if i can also address the previous
question uh for a minute which is that
one of the things that we can definitely
look at and i'll pick the example that
bjorn gave of a in his view a wrong kind
of subsidy for electric vehicles
in my view an even even bigger wrong
subsidy
is for the fossil fuel companies these
companies are getting huge subsidies
from their own exchequers and that to me
is not just wrong
that's criminal that should not be
allowed how the hell can we give
subsidies to the polluters that is
absolutely
unacceptable in this day and age
well you've got an awful lot i don't
know if you can see our audience there
but they're certainly agreeing with you
uh
many many of them i think well the vast
majority of them are clapping along
there with that well listen
uh got a lot to get through and we've
had a real sense there of the
difficult choices facing societies and
governments right now
and one society perhaps more significant
in this than
anywhere else has to make its own choice
about the future on november the third
we know where we're going don't we the
united states debate about climate
is starkly split between president trump
and joe
biden the challenger mr biden is partly
influenced
by more radical voices on the left of
his party the democrats and
one of them prospective congressman
jamal bowman told me
his country could take on the virus and
rescue
the climate at the same time
we're living through the greatest crisis
in our nation's history since
the great depression uh we're also
living through
a period similar to the spanish flu as
well as the civil rights movement
as well as economic and education
catastrophe
and climate catastrophe so i believe we
can walk and chew gum at the same time
listen before the pandemic before the
coronavirus
climate change was ravaging communities
throughout the world but what about
questions such as the financial
realities of dealing
with covid the billions upon billions
ultimately trillions of dollars that
have been spent whoever's in power
in the united states next january the
cupboard's going to be
bare isn't the money just not going to
be there for this
transition to a truly green economy when
we
have our values rooted in the right
place we invest where we need to invest
when we wanted to put a man on the moon
we were able to do that
when we wanted to bail out the big banks
in 2008
we were able to do that the real
question is do we have the resources
do we have the human capital and the
resources
to not just get out of this pandemic but
to build a nation in the world that
works for everyone
and the answer is yes we have millions
upon millions
of men women and children ready willing
and able
uh to get to work what would you say to
those developing countries who say
listen this is all well and good coming
from the mighty united states which
built its economy on the back of fossil
fuels and now you're saying you know you
won't do trade
deals with us or whatever sanctions
would be applied
if we go down the same route we have to
follow it the green way and it's going
to take us longer and be more expensive
this is about us working in
collaboration with them
being clear on what the needs are and
then taking a bottom
up strategy uh similar to what we're
doing here
in our district uh in the northeast
bronx and westchester
there are communities historically
neglected communities
that haven't been a part of this
democratic
economic climate conversation and we're
going to pull them in
have let them have a seat at the table
and make sure their voices and their
needs
are centered joe biden isn't as radical
as you are
when it comes to the climate he's a
centrist he's cautious he's going to be
hearing a lot of voices if he wins
those votes in the rust belt saying
listen we don't want to make wind
turbines we just want to get back to the
steel industry
or whatever it is he doesn't share your
vision
well joe biden is not king joe biden he
is elected by the people of this country
and he has already begun to move uh to
the left on the issue of climate change
i believe he's
committed one trillion dollars over the
next 10 years
to fight the battle of climate change a
lot more needs to be done there
but he has already moved to the left and
what about the other potential outcome
what if it's a second term
for donald trump who has in the past
said that he thinks climate change
is a hoax what happens then you know
it's interesting there's been a recent
study
uh by the financial industry on the
impact of climate change
to financial markets uh donald trump
commissioned that study so although he
says publicly
that he doesn't believe in climate
change in edison it's a hoax
the fact that that study was
commissioned and now we're looking at
the impact
on financial markets leads me to believe
that donald trump the republican party
and those who may deny the climate
catastrophe publicly
privately they understand the
ramifications of it and
are looking at it all from a financial
markets perspective
so again if trump wins we will continue
to
fight and do the work that we currently
do uh no matter how much
trump tries to change this nation into a
fascist nation
uh we will not let him and the people in
the streets
will not let him and we will demand what
needs to be done for climate and every
other issue of justice
uh in our nation well my uh interview
with jamal
bowman there and we clearly know which
side of the political landscape
he sits but what about our audience now
i suspect i already know the answer to
this question i'm going to put to you
because
i saw the look on your faces there when
we discussed donald trump and
the applause you just gave mr bowman
there at the end of the interview but
let me ask you
put up your hands if you think donald
trump's re-election would be the best
thing for the world's climate hands up
if you think donald trump's re-election
would be the best thing for the world's
climate right well okay um
well what's that two two percent well
two that's four percent fifty of you
obviously two
three perhaps and some of you some with
your heads in your hands so uh that
would be a a negative vote if you could
well
let's ask our panelists they're a very
small proportion thinking that uh
donald trump is serious when it comes to
his protestations uh about uh taking
climate change seriously of course as i
mentioned with jamal bowman there he's
also
called it a hoax so audrey gallagher
would it be
an enormous setback for the fight
against climate change
if president trump is re-elected
so um i was personally really
disappointed when i've seen that america
had pulled out the paris agreement
notwithstanding what
was spoken about the the the paris
agreement on um on climate um on the
on the panel already um we you know this
is a global issue
and it's a real concern that the world's
biggest economy isn't on board with
tackling it because that you know
it needs to be tackled globally um i
think you know there's there's no doubt
that there are
i should you know our government
probably worries about and
the competition of industrial
competitiveness
um but i think if we do this properly if
you bring investment forward in a
sensible way we can actually create jobs
you can re-skill people you can find new
jobs that
and and we can develop technology we
could we could be a world leader and we
have been a world leader on things like
offshore wind
and how quickly we've brought the costs
down to that um
and developed new technologies and i can
see the same happening again with other
um
emerging technology and i think that's
what we need to we
really need to focus on um loads of
countries out there are coming up with
their own plans about you know
the european union has got a green deal
i do think we'll get some challenges
around about you know we can't just
offshore some of these emissions
there's a lot of work to be done on um
you know
carbon border taxes and stuff like that
to make sure that we don't do that
um but there's no you know there's no
option not to do nothing here
and and that's why it's you know i'm
pleased that our country has taken a
bold step to
put it to it put the net zero target in
place by 2050 because somebody has to
take some leadership
beyond longbow what are your thoughts
would it be a disaster for the fight
against climate change if you
get a president re-elected who thinks
that things like wind turbines cause
cancer that fracking is a great thing
well look fundamentally we don't need
donald trump's
uh climate policies i think all of us in
in the panel agree on that
but the real issue and i think that's
what we need to sort of step back and
you also
ask that question to bowman is to recall
that most of the rich world is actually
a fairly small part
of the emissions in the 21st century so
if the u.s
went carbon neutral tomorrow which of
course won't happen
and stayed carbon neutral for the rest
of the century
it would if you put it into the u.n
climate models reduce temperature by the
end of the century by
0.2 degrees or a little less than that
it would probably not even be measurable
the most part of the emissions that
we're going to see in the 21st century
is about three quarters are going to
come from china
india africa latin america the world's
poor countries right now and they of
course want to get richer
they are not likely to be willing to
spend
many trillions of dollars and i think
that tells us what matters is not so
much who wins
although i would like biden to win but
it's much much more about making sure
that we pick the right targets that is
invest dramatically more
in green energy r d into zero carbon
energy technologies
because if we can make green energy
cheaper than fossil fuels
everyone will switch not just rich
well-meaning countries
but also everyone in latin america and
africa
in china and in india so i think we
should stop
focusing so much on on the us and
remember the real challenge is to get
the world's poor
it's a global challenge of course it is
and we've got a global audience and uh
what 54 of us
participating if you leave me out i'm
the moderator in this discussion 50 on
our panel and
we've identified the one person who
thinks that donald trump
would be a world leader when it comes to
climate change mahan
there you are why do you think that
well if we phrase the question
as would it be better to
leave climate change in the hands of the
private sector
or the government i think that's a
question
for particularly audrey or claire who
recently
tweeted about something like this so i'd
like to know their opinions
on that please we will find that very
soon you've done your research
that's why you're there thank you very
much indeed for that mahan we want to
talk about jobs though as well and
i will put those those points to clear
and audrey because one of the questions
for both those aspiring to become u.s
president and around governments
like the uk's is whether new green jobs
can
quickly replace those lost during the
course of this awful pandemic
well here in the uk alone our sky news
job tracker
shows that at least 129 000 jobs have
been lost
since the start of the pandemic more
than 30 000 of them
lost in the aviation sector alone well
now compare that's with the
finding of a new report by the ippr
think tank now it suggests
that low carbon energy efficient social
home
building could generate something like
560
000 jobs maybe more than that it says in
fact the think tank claims that more
than 1.6 million jobs could be created
through investing in low carbon projects
and programs
over the next decade well let's get a
question on that subject uh and it comes
from
andrew lound from birmingham of course
formerly uh the workshop
of the uk workshop of the world knows an
awful lot about manufacturing i suspect
andrew good to talk to you what is your
question
good evening yeah with japan and sweden
actively supporting hydrogen and fuel
cell technology
how can the public be sure that the true
innovation
such as hydrogen and fuel cell
technology is going to be actually
supported in the uk
especially the midlands rather than
simply being blocked and frustrated
uh by government and and the vested
interests
okay well comparing with japan and
sweden claire o'neil um
does the uk take these new technologies
their potential
for jobs and of course reduction of co2
emissions does it take it seriously
yes massively so i mean we have about
250
000 people working directly in the
low-carbon economy in the uk now and
that number's growing very rapidly every
year
and those jobs are everywhere from
aberdeen to cornwall that's a bigger
sector than the aviation sector we just
don't talk about it
and andrew you should be really proud of
the fact that um thanks to
some amazing work done uh by the former
government but
still the conservative government but
the former one we actually set up
uh some incredible innovation around
fuel cell batteries because we don't
just want to assemble cars in the uk
we want to make the batteries actually
go into the electric cars
and it was quarter of a billion pounds
invested in a thing called the faraday
challenge
uh and also in hydrogen there are lots
and lots of efforts
uh going on to actually try and drop the
cost of hydrogen but look frankly
what we need a bit more of is a bit more
public private cooperation in this space
just to go back to that that question
the private sector can't do this alone
you've got to have regulation you've got
to have things like
in fact i think carbon border taxes are
a great way of dealing with some of the
really high emitting economies who then
want to dump their steel
on some of the countries that are really
trying to clean up their act but you
know the private sector can see
innovation and can move so much more
quickly in many cases
than governments and you need these
partnerships but yes
this green stuff this clean growth
uh was at the forefront of the uk's
industrial strategy and that work does
continue and by the way birmingham is a
fantastic place
for the innovation that that sector
needs yeah but but saleem as
we've discussed this is a global problem
and it needs a global response and on
these
technologies is there a danger that the
developing world
gets left out doesn't it need the
developed world the uk's the united
states the eu's and the rest of them
to invest not just in their own
countries but in
countries like bangladesh as well
yes indeed and and but i think you know
the
the old paradigm is now history where we
in the developing world used to think
these were burdens on us
it isn't true anymore we are now also
forging ahead
on renewable energy and let me cite my
country's example
we have the biggest household energy
solar energy system in the world about
five million households
providing solar energy to 20 million
people
who weren't getting electricity before
that they were burning
kerosene and at in the night and and
that has
enhanced the quality of life of very
very poor people
living all over the country in rural
bangladesh so technological leaps and
developments
are not confined to the developed world
and they don't need to be brought from
there
to us on the other hand we can teach you
how to cope with the impacts of climate
change because we know how to do that
and you don't juan lombok do you um have
faith that these new technologies are
out there
and do and will provide solutions
oh look there are lots of solutions and
some of those as salim also mentioned
uh you know uh solar panels for very
poor people who don't have any access
wonderful thing but it's not what's
going to lift you out of poverty and of
course
at the same time as bangladesh has has
gotten a lot of solar panels they've
also seen their
uh emissions keep increasing they have
increased 15 fold over the last 50 years
because it is what drives development
and so what we
really need is to make sure that the
rich world which is thinking of spending
lots and lots of resources don't spend
it on
subsidizing existing inefficient
technology
but invested in investing in new and
research generated uh solutions so
basically make sure
we innovate new technologies that
everyone will want to do
so biden for instance he's promised a
lot of stuff and a lot of it is probably
unaffordable
but he's actually promised to increase
spending
to 75 billion dollars a year that would
be a five-fold increase of what the
world is currently doing
on research and development into sierra
carbon energy technologies
that would be a fantastic opportunity
and that is what could help
not only the rich world to deal with
this but also everyone else
because obviously you know both people
in the population and denmark and
everywhere else
would be using this yeah and let me ask
you let's just
focus again on the uk audrey gallagher i
mean part of the reason it seems that
the
uk is having such a hour with the eu
over its negotiations over a trade deal
is that
it wants the freedom to invest
particularly
in tech companies does that give you a
sign
that and of course technological
solutions we're talking about is that a
sign to you that the uk government
does take this seriously i think
the government definitely takes it
seriously claire's outlined some of the
measures that have been put in place
just recently we've seen the industrial
clusters around
um hydrogen five of them across the
whole country so there's definitely
stuff happening and
if i can i mentioned about uh the
offshore one sector that
has has we've reduced emissions in the
power generation sector by about
70 in the last 10 years a massive
success story
the only reason we were able to do that
is because
good policies get put in place backed up
by really strong environmental
protections
it gave certainty investors came forward
made that investment
developed the technology brought the
cost down massively i think like the
first round at auctions it was 150
pounds it's no less than 40.
so huge benefits so if we can take the
lessons from that
and apply them then hopefully we can
obtain the competitive advantage there
but also reduce emissions
make things cheaper for people and i
would just say as well i know we're
talking about technology
but actually really simple things like
making our homes more energy efficient
will create jobs up and down the country
it will massively reduce emissions
people will live in warmer homes they'll
be healthier
they'll save money so as well as looking
at the bright shiny stuff
we need government to be looking at how
we can do the basics
well quite a lot of applause there um
thank you very much indeed
where's the time gone we've got to our
final question then this one comes from
elizabeth baba yemi from falcook and
it's all about the these warm words
these aspirations so making sure
that they're put into action put your
question to the panel elizabeth very
good to see you
thank you dammit do we need a new
protocol
order to safeguard the world a
cross-continent panel of youths
adults and experts to evaluate the
impact on climate after covet
and the way forward great question
elizabeth well we've been talking about
the climate assembly
uh in the uk that has uh come forward
with uh
some possible solutions over the last
few months so let me put this
to you then saleem first of all do we
need
i suppose uh a new body a new global
body to think about solutions
and perhaps enforce them as well
well we already have a global body and
we have the paris agreement and we
aren't seeing a lot of enforcement going
on there i believe
in a more bottom-up approach if you like
working
from the bottom up from people who are
already
thinking about the problem and young
people in particular all over the world
in fact the youth in bangladesh are
extremely
engaged on this issue and are doing many
many things and connecting with youth
around the world as well
so to me a bottom-up citizen-led
approach
which would also take into account
people taking action themselves and also
holding their own leaders to account to
make sure the losers yeah they have the
right kind of leaders and then the right
kind of leaders take the right kind of
decisions
that's the point let me bring in audrey
gunner because that is the point isn't
it we saw you nodding along there
of course bottom-up whole population
citizens
need to be involved but do they also
need to make sure be allowed to make
sure
that what they recommend happens
yeah so already um there's
letters have given to the prime minister
the the base select committee is going
to be doing a
doing an inquiry and looking at the
recommendations that have come out with
the climate assembly and already
particularly because of the pace of
change the technology that's coming
forward
there's calls for it to be repeated um
and i think we definitely need to do
that we
we have to ensure that this gets done
the the committee on climate change does
a brilliant job in our country
um but you know there is a question
about how do you replicate that and get
it done on a global level unfortunately
i don't have the answer then i'm
really keen of particularly in the
audiences
right to be so clear neil you were you
were nodding along there with the idea
of a global
climate assembly well i love the idea of
the panel of youth experts and adults
but we already have a way to hold
governments to account in democratic
countries and that's through the ballot
box and it is you know
quite alarming that uh certainly in the
uk at the last election climate even
though people really care about this
you know what what mattered in the last
election was brexit
and secondly use our green dollars you
know companies around the world
want to be making this change want to
invest in this change but too many of us
are not exercising our
thoughts in the way that we make make
choices the way that we spend money
and so i think i i love the idea of
having this citizens assembly i can't
tell you how
how amazingly good the work is that was
done you know audrey's team
it was super pragmatic it was really
common sense it was the first time we've
actually been able to get a really good
representative view
on what people think is think is right
um but also
you know we don't vote about this so we
tend to think this is important and then
we all go back and start you know
worrying about other things so if we're
gonna say let's exercise that power
we've got
um there are lots of solutions out there
as has been said this people are taking
this seriously it's very hard to enforce
these things internationally
but we can vote beyond lombok um would
it just
just end up being just another talking
shop but
it isn't the un and the existing global
bodies aren't they adequate
well certainly we we got to be
honest and say we've made lots and lots
of promises the last 30 years
and we can see almost no impact so the
un environment agency uh
un environment program last year told us
that despite you know trillions of
dollars spent lots of people making lots
of arguments
we can't actually see the difference in
temperature or
in emission trajectories so really we
should ask ourselves
should we go on doing what has not
worked for the last 30 years
or do we need to find another way and as
clara also point out another way that
can actually get a majority at the
ballot box and i think
we need to do that by making sure we do
something that's effective
that is reasonably cheap so you can
actually get people to vote for it and
keep voting for it
and something that'll actually fix
climate change so samuel said yes
absolutely let's get rid of fossil fuel
subsidies
let's also make sure that we spend
resources on an
innovation so that we can actually get
the green revolution going
and then let's make sure that we also
deal with the other problems like covet
as we started out talking about well
thank you all very much indeed for that
on the panel well we're talking about
getting
people involved well we've got uh our
audience there of course and we let's
involve you one more time in this uh
television version of our debate and uh
let's put
elizabeth's question back to you i want
to ask you do you agree that
a global panel something like the uk
climate
assembly but on a global scale don't
know how many people would be involved
in it
is one way forward a global climate
assembly
hands up if you support an idea like
that
i'm seeing some of you may some of you
making up your mind started about oh
about three quarters now gone up to 80
90 percent i'd say that one other
question
on that issue then so you've got this
assembly
it's sitting it's deliberating it's
coming up with its suggestions it's
going to worry
the governments aren't going to act on
it do you think it should be given i
don't know how it would happen
but just we haven't got much time it
should be given some enforcement
powers hands up if you think it should
again three three quarters slightly less
well and there we must end it thank you
very much indeed to all our wonderful
audience and our wonderful thoughtful
and erudite
panel may i say thank you all and that
was
climate after covert a green recovery
and the debate's going to continue on
sky news digital platforms now we're
going to be putting more of your
questions plenty of them coming in
as well as more from our audience
they're staying with us to our panel you
can see
that show continue on the sky news
website it's
also there on our mobile app and indeed
on
our youtube channel as well and as part
of that we're going to be hearing in
just a moment or two from one of the
stars
a great comedian of the american version
of the office on his conversion
to the climate course
all i was doing was occasionally sending
out an angry tweet
you know i was what i call uh and what i
call a slacktivist
and i knew that that wasn't going to cut
it
now then you're watching climate after
covid a green
recovery we've finished on sky news
television but where continuing i'm sure
you're very glad to hear on sky news
online
and on all our digital platforms in a
moment we're going to be putting some of
your questions so many of them coming in
to a new panel but first
rain wilson is better known perhaps to
millions as dwight in the u.s version
of the office well now he's presenting
an online show the
idiot's guide to climate change i'm sure
he's not and
he's spoken to some of the environmental
movements
biggest names including the likes of
greater dunberg
our climate change correspondent lisa
holland spoke to him
like so many people uh so many
well-meaning people
i was really upset by what i was reading
about climate change
and now by the way with california being
on fire i'm even
more upset but uh all i was doing was
occasionally sending out an angry tweet
you know i was what i call uh and what i
call a slacktivist
um and i knew that that wasn't going to
cut it so
i got involved with this non-profit
called arctic base camp
and dr gail whiteman who actually lives
and teaches in the uk
and their whole point is to study the
science of climate change from the point
of view of the arctic their
catchphrases what happens in the arctic
doesn't stay in the arctic
i decided to document it and i realized
that i needed to do something more
than just a couple of angry tweets
you've obviously got
a huge following from the office you've
obviously got a lot of influence on
twitter
but did people find that it was a bit of
a turn-off because it was a serious
subject compared to comedy what sort of
response did you get
the response has been exactly what you'd
expect you know there's climate change
deniers who have all of their usual kind
of
talking points and people that are very
concerned but
what we were trying to do with this
particular show was reached that that
middle demographic that might be
confused that might be in the middle it
might be on the fence
maybe they live in mid-america and
they've got a conservative uncle
who doesn't buy the science and then
they've got friends at school that do by
the science
and they don't know what to think so
this was really a show for them
what evidence is there that you
succeeded with that
i don't know about the evidence i mean
unfortunately you can't kind of
read the tea leaves of the comments on
the youtube page and to kind of
determine
the outcome but that's all we can try
and do
just try and nudge the needle a little
bit
here and there try and shift uh
consciousness
it's the same thing that's happening in
the united states right now with racial
justice
you know like there's a whole set of
people that they're never gonna change
their minds they're never gonna believe
that there's
such a thing as white privilege or that
african-americans
are suffering in systemic racism forget
them
they're never going to change but maybe
some people in the middle that we can uh
cajole and tweak and coax and reason
with
that uh might come on board back in the
in the united states at the moment
you're experiencing wildfires you're
experiencing
really hot temperatures do you think
that those sorts of conditions
make people think twice data doesn't
work
but for some reason these extreme
cataclysmic weather events
that weren't happening with this kind of
intensity and regularity
20 or 30 years ago are starting to shift
the needle and starting to shift the
dial the rest of america just like the
uk europe and the rest of the world
has been severely affected by
coronavirus how much do you think that's
thrown people
off course in terms of really gathering
momentum to deal with climate change
obviously an international pandemic that
is
actively killing people uh is going to
take
priority and it should take priority
it's not an either or
okay it's yes it's a priority but there
is is not like let's forget climate
change let's forget racial justice and
only
work on the pandemic right now no
we need to work on all of these things
and if anything
the pandemic can be this is a test run
for humanity
working together to overcome issues of
great odds
uh of great scope a great international
scope
we can do this as a human species
inhabiting this planet
not as the denizens of bolivia and the
netherlands and mongolia all just
working in their little
fiefdoms but working together
internationally
after this pandemic we can't go back to
normal
we really we really cannot afford to go
back to normal
this affords us an opportunity for a
giant reset
you know a giant reboot uh of
our priorities uh moving forward in the
absence of
any kind of global leadership or
leadership from central governments
um how important is it do you think for
individuals to take action
this is my favorite topic of all and
this is one of the most important topics
there is
this is the trouble with climate change
in it and it sucks
sorry there's no better word for it is
that i as an individual can't do very
much
and that is incredibly frustrating so
you have a lot of people thinking
well i'm just one person i can eat beef
you know i can have lots of food waste i
can drive a
you know an old truck that creates a lot
of diesel exhaust
what difference do i make i'm just this
is seven billion people on the planet
and giant corporations and giant
governments
what difference do i make but you make a
huge difference
we make a huge difference we all make a
huge difference because yes one person
doesn't
uh tip the scales but you know a
thousand
maybe ten thousand does then if a
hundred thousand people are all doing
the same thing
if a million people quit eating beef if
10 million people
start to reduce their their carbon
footprint if a hundred million people
start changing their ways
start commuting with bicycles instead of
with cars
all of a sudden we can see an impact so
we need to shift our behaviors we need
to take our friends and family
and co-workers and facebook friends and
everyone else along with us
and we are going to need to make
personal sacrifices
we love in the western world to have a
life of total convenience where we can
hit a button on amazon and anything we
want shows up at our doorstep a day or
two later
but we're going to have to shift things
to have a longer-term
view we've got to plant trees
support environmental organizations and
most importantly
we have to vote for science vote for
people that are behind the science do
you feel optimistic
i feel optimistic that uh
big changes can be made and we can get
ourselves out of the worst
of this um it's very easy to get
pessimistic when you look at the data
and we look at some of the things that
happen
but there is a movement among young
people and that's where i feel my
greatest optimism
is what we just explored in the idiot's
guide to climate change
is that this leadership like greta
tunberg who i got to interview
and katie hyder and so many other people
that
young women people in their teens in
their 20s are leading the charge
and helping make the change and we need
to get out of the way
allow them to lead and that's really
inspiring the amount of young people
that are behind the kind of drastic
change that humanity is going to need to
make
to fix this thing the idiot's guide to
climate change there by the wonderful
rain wilson interviewed by the equally
wonderful lisa holland so
what questions has our programme raised
for you well i've got some right here
to put to our panel and uh joining us
for this purpose are shape tanya kumar
head of environment at the new economics
foundation carsten young also joins us
senior economist
at the institute for public policy
research and
remaining with us is audrey gallagher
who
served on the advisory board to the
climate assembly
uk so lots more to put to them coming in
from all our
viewers listeners etc and uh we've got
our first question it comes to peter
from london whose email to say
to what extent if any has the human
pollution
of the environment contributed to the
emergence
of covid 19. now i suppose this the
point being that it's a zoonotic disease
which has
got into humans from animals from bats
or pangolins or
or from some source like that let me
start with you then chaitanya
what are your thoughts about human
actions and covet 19.
well there is emerging evidence to
suggest
that uh some of the wet markets uh in
china and other parts of the country
world um where there's not much
regulation there's not much
oversight on what is happening in these
places there is
uh sort of viruses uh spreading without
much
control uh in these places and we knew
uh for quite a while now i think the
last report that was talking about
uh a novel coronavirus uh spreading
across the world
was back in 2007 8. so we knew this was
a ticking time bomb
and 2020 was the year when we when we
saw this uh
spread across the world so the emergence
the evidence is there
but uh we need much more uh scientific
backing
to that okay and i should have said
welcome to the panel as well chaitanya
very good
to see you and welcome to carson jung
your thoughts on that and i suppose we
should also encompass you know
growing global populations moving
into cutting down forests moving into
areas
populated by animals and of course short
of food in some areas
that's right so where is it still
unclear
what exactly was the origin of this
particular coronavirus
we know that the risk of
new viruses is increasing by
by humans encroaching more and more on
habitats
of uh
of hit the two preserved areas
so um you know but by cutting into
pristine
rainforests by um
using farming practices in hitherto
protected land
the chance is just increasing that
viruses
jump over from animals to humans so i
think there is some truth to
to the question yeah okay audrey
and uh thanks for staying with us some
to what extent has human pollution of
the environment contributed
to the emergence of kobe 19 are there
other factors in terms of pollution
so with definitely no questions like
that i'm wishing i hadn't stayed with
you because i'm not an
epidemiologist uh energy policy so
well certainly when it comes to as we've
seen with uh stuart ramsey
in brazil when it comes to burning and
as carsten was touching on there when it
comes to burning down
rainforests there's a there's a direct
feed through isn't there
into climate change yeah and i think
it's all interconnected but i i would
want to be careful that we
we didn't you know there is enough we
have enough problems kind of
climate change that we um that we don't
we don't
start creating them so let's make sure
that the evidence is there and you know
from what the other panelists are saying
i'm no expert
um it needs to be yeah
listen i'll tell you what audrey this uh
next question is more up your street so
you're
you're getting this one um i've had a
look at it in advance because hazel jiwa
sent it in
on whatsapp and uh oslo asks there are
several says there are 700 global
corporate polluters uh is the challenge
to get corporations who are the main
culprits to act rather than the public
is is that it is that i mean given the
scale of some of these vast
corporations and what they're pumping
out into the atmosphere into the seas
isn't it better that they are dealt with
first before the public have to change
their behaviors
what do you think audrey yeah so i think
without a doubt and and most companies
now are having to come up with business
plans which
you know ensure that they're staying
below to two degrees of one and a half
degrees
we have seen quite a lot of action
around um
divesting shares so you know lots of
universities now will not
and that will not have their pension
funds and companies that are pollutants
so
the message is definitely out there
corporately certainly all our members
100 committed to reaching net zero
everybody has clear plans for
decarbonisation
and also not even just their own
businesses but how can they help their
customers you know we have
we have energy retailers in our
membership who have come
have have come out with clear plans to
help the customers become much more
energy efficient and to reach next zero
in their own homes
so undoubtedly companies have got to do
this we've all got to do you know it's
got to be it's a partnership
everybody's got to deliver and carson
young i mean
as an economist let's be blunt about
this isn't the best way
of getting these mighty multinationals
to
convert to being carbon friendly is
telling them
actually you can make some money out of
this as well
absolutely climate change
is a huge business opportunity for
firms that adapt to the new world
and invest in future-proof products
and some firms already have made a
fortune out of that
and recent headlines were at tesla
uh you know reaching a record valuation
because
they saw that electro mobility
is the future or is part of the future
so that's an example of
how you can make money so it's
absolutely right
that firms need to make plans
how do they get their emissions to net
zero
uh by the middle of the century but i
would also say
um the rest of the economy needs to do
this as well
you know we need to move to electric
cars we need to insulate our homes
and the companies need to provide the
products that we need
that's that's a very interesting point
uh which i'd like you chetanya to
to take on as well because uh the the
other part of
oslo's question is that right
concentrate on the corporate polices
there are so many of them and their
emissions are
so vast uh concentrate on them rather
than the public
is the question but does that in a way
then if that were the policy would that
not give
individuals a free pass well they say
look what's the point of me
altering my behavior because look at
that corporation it
spans the globe and look at what it's
doing what difference can i make
well we heard the uh the american actor
earlier talking about
the frustration that people have when
you realize that as an individual
there's very little that one could do
but i mean we're sort of sort of stuck
in this
if i can call it a dirty dance with the
corporations where if you
challenge the corporations you basically
get a response saying well you do rely
on our products
and we do we use facebook we drive on
cars
we rely on these products quite a lot
but the question is how do we
challenge them to change their practices
you're saying individuals can do more
yes indeed change your personal
behaviors and your family's behaviors
but there's things you can do to
influence these companies
absolutely yes and we've seen examples
of that in the past um
we've seen shareholder activism change
uh
investment practices of companies we've
seen uh protests and
public mobilization against corporations
that
we're running sweatshops for in the
global south for instance so
you've seen public pressure uh and
consumer pressure
actually bring about change in these
corporations yeah but i mean the danger
is on that carson young isn't it that um
some companies just realize it's quite a
good marketing ploy
they serve they you know it's lip
service and they know it'll go down well
with their consumers but they're not
really committed
there is of course the risk that
companies just
engage in greenwashing and it's all just
glossy marketing
and that's why we also need regulation
and we need the government to make sure
that firms actually
you know adjust their ways and invest in
the right types of technologies
uh you know and sometimes that's a
penalizing polluting behavior
but often it means subsidizing uh
clean behavior so the government for
instance uh has put out a
uh five thousand pound voucher uh for
everyone who insulates their home
and that's a great start that's a great
way of making people
uh you know make their houses more
energy efficient
and that needs to be rolled out into
other areas like transportation
and also helping businesses to make
their processes more clean
so it's both businesses and the market
needing to
push in the one direction but also the
government coming with a stick
and ensuring they actually do it and
some carrot as well i
i don't know if you've seen my next
question there carsten you seem to have
anticipated it a bit but it's a very
specific one you'll hear it right now
comes from philip smith lawrence uh
what's up to us
and wants to know very as i say specific
question is there any
tangible plan to decarbonize heating
in the uk um ordinary a tangible plan
because
i mean it all looks pretty expensive
doesn't it changing away from the old
boilers and such like hydrogens
expensive heat pumps
solar panels things like that
yeah so we're waiting on the government
coming out with heat strategy so we can
find out what happens
what's going to happen um there's um
there's some legislation on the books
potentially
that there'll be no more gas boilers in
new build homes after 2025
and i think the issue that we've got
here is we
we we don't know what's going to work we
know it's going to be expensive
it's going to be disruptive and i don't
know but you i like my gas boiler it's
dead convenient and it keeps house warm
and it's relatively cheap
so so we have got a huge challenge on my
hands here
um and i think you know it's that thing
about not imposing things on people
either
so what we've been calling for is can we
get some trials
so you have to go out and see what works
because you've probably not got a single
solution we're not probably going we're
not going to build another gas network
i think there are some opportunities to
put hydrogen into the gas network we've
seen some hybrid boilers you can have
district heating networks you can have
ground source heat pumps and loads of
stuff out there
and what we are calling for is like as
well as the government coming up with
strategy
let's get some proper trials out there
let's get some decarbonized heating
systems down about a million homes in
the next few years
just so we can find out what works and
then roll it out at scale
good idea i mean but you say we're still
waiting for
the some of the specifics from the
government and uh let me put that to you
chaitanya some of the the specifics we
know about have gone in
recently have gone in the opposite
direction and they for instance grants
have been cut for
solar panels and electric cars and
things like that
yes they have been but it's also a
function of the markets because
the cost of solar energy has fallen so
dramatically that the government
saw it fit to not continue subsidizing
it further
unfortunately it did not give enough of
a
notice let's say to a lot of small
businesses people
wanting to put up solar panels on their
rooftop uh and they couldn't so
it's a challenge uh it's always a
challenge for any policymaker to figure
out the trade-offs between
how how long do you keep subsidizing a
certain technology before you pull back
uh and allow the market to sort of take
over um but when it comes to sort of
heating it's very important to
understand this this very
basic fact it's hard to replace
the entire energy infrastructure which
is now driven by fossil fuels
one-to-one with clean energy because
it's just too much energy that we
consume
the best and the first and the cheapest
solution we've
got is efficiency if you cut down the
amount of energy we consume
the the remainder of the energy we
consume could actually be
uh supported or or brought in by cleaner
sources like hydrogen like heat pumps
like distributing the examples that
audrey was giving so the first most
critical solution is
energy efficiency and carson was talking
about the 5 000 pound vouchers
that's a good example this government
committed
9.2 billion pounds in its manifesto uh
last year and we haven't seen a lot of
that yet we've only seen a third of that
being
put out yet yeah maybe it's rethinking
that who knows but just on that issue
again you you touched on it let's expand
it carsten
because the previous contributor in the
television part
of this exercise pointed out when it
comes to subsidies and i mentioned there
things like
electric vehicles well okay it's a
subsidy i think it was about three and a
half thousand pounds
it's been cut they're still awfully
expensive so all you do is allow
already rich people to buy them a bit
more cheaply it applies also to hydrogen
boilers they're about 12 grand or
something like that
so you cut a couple of thousand off and
it makes no difference to people who
can't afford that kind of money does it
i wouldn't agree with that actually the
issue
of um clean energy in houses
affects you know the majority of people
in the country
in fact at two-thirds of homes in the uk
don't fit the standard that the
government itself has
said they should achieve so two-thirds
of houses
uh are not very efficient and that's
really bad
for climate change also two and a half
million
people live in fuel poverty uh because
they cannot afford to heat their homes
uh given the prices and given how poorly
insulated they are
so this is really an issue that touches
you know across demographics in the
country
and investing in insulating homes you
know it will have tangible benefits
for people and their uh their pockets
because they will save money on energy
bills okay
right division of opinion there let's
move on
uh because of so many dimensions to
cover so many great questions
coming in from our audience and this one
sarah thank you sarah from east
yorkshire
uh who says this we're onto single-use
plastics again we did
touch on that when it came to ppe uh
generated because of the
coronavirus pandemic but this is about
that which is going to
remain long after coronavirus has gone
uh well we hope not
anyway her question is why not stop
manufacturing
single-use plastic and excessive
packaging in supermarkets
immediately a question that future
generations may ask us
why we did not may i add to that from
sarah i had an experience very
recently with uh one of my daughters uh
had an italian boyfriend came over from
rome so the capital city we took him
around the local supermarket
his jaw hit the floor when he saw
the way that vegetables were sold in the
uk not only
pre-chopped carrots but cleaned up and
covered in plastic
that's not the way to do it i mean he
seriously
was absolutely astonished and that's
that's part of sarah's question there
that future generations
go what the heck were you doing back
in the early 21st century in the uk what
are your thoughts on that chaitanya
i mean it could be done right now
couldn't it
well a lot could be done i mean i came
to this country from the
from india about five years ago first
time i walked into sainsbury i could see
a cucumber with plastic uh
individual cucumbers plastic which i was
flabbergasted by the situation
exactly so um but as the previous panel
alluded to this point just banning
things is
is not uh the right way to go about
doing things
yes we have to cut down plastic there
are different ways of going about it
either sort of set a deadline saying
look we're going to face this out as
opposed saying
tomorrow we're going to ban this uh they
will cause uh disruption
when you walk into a supermarket you'd
expect some form of service where
you can carry your vegetables or
whatever it is back home so
um an outright ban
like not just plastic for a lot of
issues might not be the perfect solution
in this regard but there are other
things that we can do i mean the
government example
which is quite well touted is the 5b
surcharge plastic bag that's of a
certain thickness
so it's limited in its application but
nonetheless it's brought down the
consumption of plastic bags in big
supermarkets by about 95 percent over
the last sort of five six years
now that is a consequence a meaningful
result of good policy and good
tax incentives we could do the same but
apply it to a range of products
yeah well so i mean carson young that i
mean mentioning the plastic bags i was
going to do that i mean that's
that's a form of nudge a little extra
charge to discourage use and uh
it has worked or worked partially we're
now moving on to those bags for life
i know but i mean could it not then be
applied
to packaging if you want it all wrapped
up and cleaned up it's going to cost you
more well it already does but
but quite a lot more
i i agree with with chatanya that um
we should uh look closely at the at the
specific cases and
what the what the what the issue is so
uh you know
you could also broaden it to the
emissions
that you have in transportation of
certain goods that we buy
and often just making it very
transparent
how environmentally damaging the
products are
will show people what is actually the
green option and what is a very
polluting option
so so i think that transparency is an
important point
regulation is a point but also charging
more i think
they all need to play part of the need
to be part of the mix
but isn't it also just about habit
audrey gallagher i mean you know you
were on the advisory board to the
climate assembly you heard
the discussions when people have things
explained to them and we are
extraordinary
in the united kingdom the amount of
stuff that doesn't need to be that we do
wrap in plastic
if people would just just have that
explain to them how
long plastic survives in the environment
how damaging it is when it gets into the
oceans
when it gets into human systems they
would then say look we
we've got to stop this so
definitely and that's the big thing i
think one of the recommendations coming
out of the climate assembly was about um
labeling so to the to the previous point
about if you've got the information then
you can make some decisions
and and they were talking about you know
we want the carbon footprint of the
things that we're buying we want to see
what the carbon impact to that is
not just the calories so there is i
think once you start
educating people then they can make
really informed decisions which we've
seen
one of the one of the one of the big um
benefits that i've seen in the on the on
the climate assembly
and i think claire and the alluded to on
the last panel
was that by doing this it's almost um
given whether it's businesses wrapping
up cucumbers and plastics or governments
making decisions it's almost
giving them some cover and make some
bold decisions so
clearly the supermarkets are selling
fruit in that way because they think
that's what people
want but if we tell them that we don't
want that then hopefully they will stop
doing it and it's likewise for
for government if you if you set out the
issues and people make informed
decisions
then hopefully that will allow
governments to make old decisions and
companies to do the right thing but we
need to educate people
we need to we need to bring them with us
and and we need to start demanding
things from
from government and in business okay we
listen to what
we're nearly at the end of our slot so
i've got a last question here from
rod butler has got in touch with us on
what's up thank you very much indeed rod
butler and
here's your question it's really about
population i suppose it is
we have the cleanest fuel cars and
commerce for at least 100 years
why are we not focusing on population
more people means
more food transport work and housing is
required
is this not the main problem the the
number of people what is it something
like 8 billion people now on the
planet and uh indeed caitanya i mean
many climate activists have been saying
that it is now
irresponsible to have lots of children
um i i just start off by saying it's a
massive
red herring to talk about population
when it comes to climate change and
carbon emissions
um we have to look at the per capita
consumption
of say an average brit compared to an
average indian
so carbon emissions for an average
british citizen is about 10 to 11 tons
of carbon dioxide
per person per year compared to an
average indian which is about three
roughly so there is a massive disparity
and that means a lot
in terms of the kind of lifestyle one
has the kind of consumption one has
the kind of uh um well-being factors
associated with that kind of
carbon emissions it makes a world of
difference to suggest that
uh the global south countries in africa
and latin america
who are adding numbers to their
population uh
are the cause of the problem is is a
massive problem um and i think we should
be very careful
in not conflating the population issue
i'm not suggesting that we can keep
growing definitely of course not uh
there is a steady decline but
we shouldn't compare that to the climate
challenge i'd say it's a very
very thoughtful contribution that
chaitanya carsten i mean that
do you think it's a red herring as well
then it's not about
the individual it's about the country
the individual
lives in and the amount of carbon they
emit and get through
i absolutely agree with titania that a
lot of people
contribute actually very little to
climate change
but i'd also say that with the
population we have across the globe
we can solve the climate challenge we
have the technology
that we need to live good lives
and still prevent climate change
we can insulate our homes and
use heating that's renewable we can use
more public public transport
that gets us to where we want to go in a
sustainable fashion
we can restore nature which will
actually help suck carbon
out of the atmosphere and we can make
our industry
more low emission and use
new technologies most of these
technologies do
exist out there and with some
entrepreneurialism
with incentives and investment by the
government
and with some individual behavior
changes we can do this
so i think the positive message is
we don't need to give up things in order
to solve this
crisis and audrey i don't know if the uh
climate assembly uh discussed this uh if
not what i mean what are your thoughts
on that
i mean is there is there a limit to the
size of the global population
should there be so so i agree with the
what the
the previous um what the rest of the
panel is saying i think you know you
could you could do a whole
other program on some of the challenges
that we've got a country on an aging
population and
paying for social care and stuff like
that so we have there are
there are issues domestically on that i
think you know
the only thing i would add is that if we
um if we continue down this road there's
maybe serious questions about what
happens around personal carbon taxes
and how you try and you know incentivize
that behavior
or disincentivize it as a case may be um
but
i agree with the other panelists that
has been a fantastic set of
contributions
from you all what we've done about half
an hour's worth and
what have we got through there uh
single-use plastic of the role of
corporations
when it comes to co2 emissions
heating uh population much much more as
well thank you all very much indeed for
your
thoughtful contributions chaitanya kumar
carsten young
and audrey gallagher very good to talk
to you all
and uh that is it for climate after
covid thank you to
our panel for taking part and indeed for
you for watching
and for participating some really great
questions there thank you very much
indeed for now it's
goodbye
you